bonjour à tous aujourd'hui ensemble nous
allons visiter un endroit exceptionnel
ici au cern à genève se trouve une des
machines les plus extraordinaire jamais
construite par l'être humain
le lhc le lhc c'est le plus grand et le
plus puissant accélérateur de particules
au monde
vous savez peut-être il a notamment été
conçu dans le but de débusquer le fameux
boson de higgs une entreprise couronnée
de succès puisque cette découverte a été
annoncée ici même au cern le 4 juillet
ensemble aujourd'hui nous allons
explorer le lhc en essayant de
comprendre les incroyables défis
scientifiques et technologiques qu'il a
fallu relever pour mettre la main sur
cette particule insaisissable
[Musique]
le boson de higgs vous êtes peut-être
déjà demandé pour quelle raison on parle
autant de cette particule est pourquoi
elle fascine à ce point les physiciens
et bien c'est parce qu'elle représente
la toute dernière pièce d'un grand
puzzle scientifiques dont la résolution
aura duré presque un demi siècle entre
les années 1950 et 1960
de nombreux physiciens ont travaillé à
bâtir une grande théorie censé expliquer
toute la structure fondamentale de la
matière
on appelle cette théorie le modèle
standard de la physique des particules
ce modèle fait appel à ces ce type de
particules élémentaires qui permettent
d'expliquer la totalité des formes de
matières et l'ensemble de ces
interactions dans le monde de
l'infiniment petit mais pour tenir
debout
cette théorie ambitieuse avait besoin
d'un ingrédient supplémentaire
une dix-septième particules ayant pour
lourde tâche d'expliquer l'existence de
la masse des autres particules
fondamentales
cette ultime pièce du puzzle c'est le
fameux boson de higgs
aujourd'hui je ne vais pas revenir sur
ce rôle théorique du boson de higgs
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le faire dans
une vidéo précédente sur le sujet
puisqu'on a la chance d'être au cern
je voudrais plutôt me concentrer sur les
formidable prouesse qu'il a fallu
accomplir pour mettre en évidence cette
particule presque un demi-siècle après
qu'elle ait été imaginé par françois
englert proverbe route et pieter ickx et
pour bien comprendre pourquoi nous avons
eu besoin d'une machine aussi
extraordinaire que le lhc pour attraper
son boson de higgs
je voudrais commencer par revenir dans
le temps pour vous expliquer comment on
s'y prend pour découvrir de nouvelles
particules projetons nous presque 90 ans
en arrière en 1932 cette année là on
vient de démontrer l'existence du
neutron et eisenberg propose alors son
modèle de l'atome qui est celui que nous
connaissons bien et qu'on trouve dans
les manuels scolaires anatomy est
représenté comme un noyau formé de
protons chargés positivement et deux
neutrons et autour duquel on trouve des
électrons chargées négativement
si on ajoute à cela le photon pour la
lumière toute la structure de la matière
semblait alors pouvoir s'expliquer avec
l'aide de ses quatre particules sauf
qu'à partir de l'année 1932 on a
commencé à en trouver tout un tas
d'autres des particules qui nous avait
échappé jusqu'ici et ce pour une bonne
raison
elle n'existe pas de façon stable à
l'état naturel c'est par exemple le cas
d'union un lointain cousin des électrons
dont la durée de vie est de seulement 2
seconde malgré cette existence éphémère
des muons son produit en permanence par
les collisions des rayons cosmiques qui
viennent frapper les molécules de
l'atmosphère du fait de leur durée de
vie si courte
les muons avait échappé à l'oeil des
physiciens de l'époque mais dans les
années 30 on a pu découvrir leur
existence grâce à un détecteur très
simple une chambre à brouillard la
chambre brouillard c'est une sorte
d'aquarium étanche est saturé de vapeurs
d'alcool quand une particule traverse la
chambre elle laisse une traînée derrière
elle provoqué par la condensation
l'alcool ce qui trahit sa présence et
permet ainsi de visualiser sa
trajectoire alors savoir qu'une
particule vient de passer c'est bien
mais encore faut-il pouvoir l'a
caractérisé et l'identifier une façon de
le faire c'est de placer la chambre à
brouillard dans un champ magnétique
on sait en effet qu'un champ magnétique
courbes les trajectoires des particules
qui possède une charge
c'est ainsi qu'on a pu observer que
certaines trajectoires dans les chambres
à brouillard se courbaient mais de façon
bien moins prononcée que celle des
électrons cela a permis de comprendre
qu'on avait là des particules inconnu au
bataillon chargé négativement comme
l'électron mais environ 200 fois plus
lourde ces particules qu'on a fini par
baptisé les murs cette histoire de la
découverte des muons est assez ancien
mais elle illustre bien les deux
ingrédients qui sont toujours nécessaire
lorsqu'on est à la recherche de
nouvelles particules d'un côté puisqu'il
s'agit de particules qui n'existent pas
à l'état naturel il faut un moyen de les
produire dans le cas des muons c'était
les rayons cosmiques qui jouait ce rôle
et de l'autre il faut pouvoir les
caractériser et les identifier et à
l'époque on utilisait donc une chambre à
brouillard avec un champ magnétique
depuis les années 30 l'histoire de la
physique des particules expérimental est
allée de pair avec l'évolution des
moyens techniques permettant de produire
et détecter de nouvelles particules du
côté de la création de particules on a
fondamentalement besoin que d'un seul
ingrédient de l'énergie et ce d'autant
plus qu'on cherche à créer des
particules massives
c'est l'indécence de la fameuse relation
e égal mc carey on l'a dit dans le cas
des murs cette énergie provenaient des
collisions des rayons cosmiques avec les
particules de l'atmosphère
mais pour pouvoir produire et découvrir
toujours plus de nouvelles particules il
a fallu faire appel à des collisions
artificielle et donc à des accélérateurs
de particules
le principe de base en est assez simple
on prend une particule de départ qui
possède une charge par exemple un
électron un proton et on l'a fait passer
dans un champ électrique pour
l'accélérer c'est comme ça que
fonctionne le canon à électrons qu'on
retrouve notamment dans les tubes
cathodiques des vieilles télévisions en
envoyant ensuite ces particules accès
est entré en collision avec un matériau
on libère de l'énergie susceptible de
donner naissance à de nouvelles
particules l'énergie de collisions
obtenu avec un tel système dépend de la
charge de la particule accéléré et de la
tension utilisés et donc pour simplifier
les calculs les physiciens utilise une
unité qu'on appelle lé électronvolts
noté élevé par exemple 1000 électron
volt c'est l'énergie cinétique d'un
électron qui a été accélérée dans une
tension de 1000 volts et ce serait
pareil avec un proton d'ailleurs et on
utilise aussi les multiples de cette
unité
donc vous allez m'entendre parler de
kilos électronvolts méga électronvolts
gigaélectron volt et même
téraélectronvolt une limite de cette
technique d'accélération c'est qu'il est
difficile de créer et de maintenir une
tension statique supérieur à quelques
centaines de milliers de volts et donc
les énergies de collisions que l'on peut
atteindre dépasse difficilement disons
un méga électron volt pour s'affranchir
de cette limitation il existe une
solution s'arranger pour que les
particules qu'on accélère reviennent
passer plusieurs fois de suite dans le
même champ électrique avant d'être
libéré cela nécessite de pouvoir
contrôler leur trajectoire et on peut le
faire avec un autre champ que j'ai déjà
mentionné le champ magnétique en effet
puisque le champ magnétique courbe de la
trajectoire des particules chargées
on peut s'en servir pour leur faire
suivre un trajet circulaire ou en
spirale
en combinant ainsi des champs
électriques et magnétiques on peut créer
ce qu'on appelle un cyclotron qui permet
de faire passer plusieurs fois les
particules dans la tension accélératrice
et donc d'atteindre des énergies bien
plus importante que le simple canon à
électrons depuis beaucoup d'innovations
ont été apportées et de nouveaux types
d'accélérateur ont été créés comme par
exemple et les synchrotrons les
différentes améliorations ont permis
d'atteindre des énergies de plus en plus
élevés dans les collisions et donc de
produire et de découvrir de plus en plus
de nouvelles particules mais pour le
boson de higgs de c'est une autre
histoire
il s'agit en effet d'une particule qu'on
supposait très massive et donc
nécessitant beaucoup d'énergie et de
surcroît très difficile à produire
il a donc fallu faire appel à de
nouvelles technologies celle du lhc dont
les premiers plans ont été imaginé dès
les années 80
[Musique]
le lhc est l'accélérateur de particules
de tous les extrêmes un anneau
circulaire d'une circonférence de 27 km
située à 175 mètres sous terre
ici à la frontière franco suisse et
permettant de réaliser des collisions de
protons à l'énergie jamais vu de 14
téraélectronvolt pour obtenir cette
énergie de collision on n'utilise pas un
faisceau venant frapper une cible fixe
mais deux faisceaux tournant en sens
opposés l'un de l'autre et que l'on fait
se rencontrer à des endroits bien choisi
de leur trajectoire
outre des protons le lhc peut également
accéléré des noyaux de plots on regroupe
l'ensemble sous le terme générique de
hadrons d'où son nom large hadron
collider mais bien qu'on parle toujours
de lui le lhc ne fait pas le travail
tout seul il n'est que le dernier
maillon d'une chaîne d'accélérateur de
plus en plus puissants dont l'objectif
est d'amener progressivement les protons
jusqu'à leur énergie maximale
tout commence avec une simple bouteille
d'hydrogène dont on extrait les protons
qui seront accélérés tout au long du
processus
ceux ci débutent leur voyage dans un
accélérateur linéaire puis sont transmis
aux booster qui les livrent au
synchrotron puis au super synchrotron
avant d'être injecté progressivement
dans l'anneau du lhc
c'est au moment de cette injection que
le flux de proton est scindé en deux de
façon à pouvoir alimenter les deux
faisceaux qui composent l'anneau du ls
les protons des deux faisceaux seront
alors accéléré jusqu'à l'énergie de 7
téraélectronvolts permettant d'atteindre
14 téraélectronvolt au moment des
collisions pour atteindre ces énergies
fantastique
le lhc se base essentiellement sur les
mêmes principes physiques que les autres
accélérateur un champ électrique pour
accélérer les particules et un champ
magnétique pour contrôler leur
trajectoire dans l'année mais tout ça
d'une façon bien plus complexe qu'un
simple cyclotron le champ électrique
utilisée est ce qu'on appelle un champ
radiofréquences résonnant qui permet
d'atteindre des accélérations bien plus
élevée que celle d'un champ électrique
statique ce champ est appliquée dans les
cavités radiofréquences du lhc
on en compte seize le long de la
trajectoire 8 par faisceau ces cavités
permettent en quelque sorte de donner un
petit coup de fouet énergétique aux
particules qui les traversent
cela représente quelques méga
électronvolts par passage mais à force
de tourner dans l'anneau l'énergie des
protons passe progressivement de 450
gigaélectron volt
à 7 téraélectronvolts mais entre ces
cavités accélératrice les protons
doivent suivre la forme circulaire de
l'anneau du lhc et pour contrôler cette
trajectoire on a besoin d'un champ
magnétique
les 27 kilomètres qui composent l'anneau
du lhc sont principalement formés de
structures élémentaires comme celle ci
qu'on appelle des dipôles chaque dit
paul mesure 15 mètres de long et pèse 35
tonnes à l'intérieur deux tubes de
seulement quelques centimètres de
diamètre qui contiennent les deux
faisceaux tournant en sens opposés l'un
de l'autre
afin d'assurer la bonne courbure de la
trajectoire ces tubes sont le siège d'un
champ magnétique énorme
en effet plus la vitesse des protons est
importante plus le champ magnétique doit
être élevé pour les maintenir sur la
bonne trajectoire
ce chant augmente donc progressivement
au fur et à mesure de l'accélération des
protons jusqu'à atteindre la valeur
monstrueuse de 8 et cela soit cent mille
fois plus que le champ magnétique
terrestre pour produire ce champ
magnétique colossal on utilise des
électroaimants que l'on distingue ici
vous connaissez peut-être le principe de
l'électro et man il s'agit d'une bobine
de fil et plus le courant qu'on y fait
circuler est élevé plus le champ
magnétique produit au centre de la
bobine sera important pour obtenir 8 et
cela avec cette configuration il faut y
faire circuler un courant dont
l'intensité a atteint 12 milles en terre
de telle intensité on n'en trouve nulle
part évidemment dans nos installations
électriques domestiques un appareil
électroménager c'est généralement
quelques ampère au maximum ça peut
atteindre une dizaine dans père dans le
cas des appareils chauffants comme les
bouilloires électriques ou les grille
pain qui exploite justement le fait que
plus l'intensité électrique est élevé
plus la chaleur dégagée sera importante
donc à première vue un courant
électrique de 12 mille ans perd ça
devrait dégager une chaleur monstrueuse
de quoi faire s'évaporer le lac léman à
côté heureusement il existe une solution
pour s'en sortir c'est d'utiliser pour
les électro aimants des fils électriques
pas comme les autres des
supraconducteurs un supraconducteur
c'est un matériau capable de conduire le
courant sans aucune résistance
électrique et donc sans dégagement de
chaleur ni pertes inutiles
il n'existe que très peu de matériaux de
ce genre dans le cas du lhc on utilise
un alliage de niobium et de titane le
seul souci c'est que comme pour tous les
matériaux de ce genre l'effet
supraconducteurs ne se manifeste qu'à
des températures extrêmement basses tous
les aimants du lhc sont donc refroidi
jusqu'à la température glaciale de moins
271 degrés celsius environ 2 degrés au
dessus du zéro absolu
à titre de comparaison c'est juste un
tout petit peu plus froid que l'espace
intersidéral et pour refroidir tout le
lhc
on utilise 12 mille tonnes d'azoté
liquide et 700 mètres cubes d'hélium
super fluide permettant de refroidir 270
mille kilomètres de câbles
supraconducteurs
le lhc ce sont donc des courants
électriques extrêmes des températures
extrêmes des champs électromagnétiques
extrême mais également un vide extrême
en effet pour éviter que les protons qui
circulent ne vienne entré en collision
avec les molécules de l'air ambiant
il règne dans les tubes une pression
diminue milliard de fois inférieures à
la pression atmosphérique ce qui en fait
un des endroits les plus vite du système
solaire les 10 pôles comme celui ci ne
sont pas les seuls briques qui
permettent de construire l'anneau du lhc
il existe de nombreux types dément ayant
chacun une fonction spécifique comme par
exemple les quadripôle qui permettent de
focaliser le faisceau et éviter sa
dispersion
pour vous donner une idée de la
précision des réglages et des
ajustements nécessaires pour garder le
faisceau sur sa trajectoire
sachez que les opérateurs du cern
doivent tenir compte des mouvements et
des phases de la lune qui dit la très
légèrement l'anneau selon un phénomène
analogue à celui des marais je me trouve
maintenant dans le centre de contrôle du
cern
c'est d'ici que sont pilotés toutes les
installations permettant d'accélérer les
protons jusqu'au bon niveau d'énergie
pour pouvoir procéder aux expériences de
collision je voulais dit le lhc reçoit
ses proton d'un accélérateur plus petit
le super synchrotron qui les a déjà
porté à l'énergie de 450 gigaélectron
volt c'est proton sont ensuite injecté
progressivement pour alimenter les deux
faisceaux de l'anneau du lhc qui les
amènera à l'énergie de 7
téraélectronvolts le total de
l'opération prenant environ une
vingtaine de minutes chaque faisceau se
structure de la façon suivante les
protons sont regroupés en 2008 100
paquets espacés de 7 mètres tout au long
de l'anneau un paquet ne mesure que
quelques centimètres de long et 1 mm de
diamètre et contient environ 100
milliards de protons à la fin de la
phase d'accélération les paquets de
protons circulent à une vitesse très
proche de celle de la lumière 299
millions sept cent quatre-vingt douze
mille quatre cent cinquante cinq mètres
par seconde là où la lumière c'est 299
millions 792 1458 mètres par seconde
l'anneau mesurant 27 km à cette vitesse
là ils accomplissent 11245 tour par
seconde au maximum l'énergie contenue
dans chaque faisceau équivaut à 80 kilos
de tnt
il vaut donc mieux ne pas en perdre le
contrôle c'est une fois la phase d'axel
ration terminé que les collisions
peuvent commencer ces collisions entre
les deux faisceaux de protons sont
réalisés sur des points de croisement
situés à des endroits bien précis de la
trajectoire nous sont placés les quatre
détecteurs dont nous parlerons tout à
l'heure sachant que chacun des 2800
paquet effectué 11245 tour par seconde
vous pouvez faire la multiplication cela
représente 30 millions de croisement par
seconde à chaque point de rencontre afin
d'être certain que chaque croisement
engendre le maximum de collision à
l'entrée des détecteurs les faisceaux
sont focalisés et concentré grâce à des
aimants spécifiques qui permettent de
réduire le diamètre des paquets à
seulement 16 micron quand les faisceaux
sont bien réglés cela permet d'obtenir
environ 20 collision à chaque croisement
de paquets leur vin ça peut paraître peu
puisque chaque paquet contient 100
milliards de protons
cela signifie que quand deux paquets se
croiser il se passe très largement au
travers l'un de l'autre et pourtant
au rythme où vont les faisceaux 20
collision par croisement cela représente
600 millions de collisions par seconde
ce taux de collision est un indicateur
de performance important qui correspond
à ce qu'on appelle la luminosité de
l'accélérateur de façon générale plus la
luminosité d'un accélérateur est élevé
plus on augmentera les chances de
produire et détecter les particules
qu'on cherche
cela va sans dire le lhc est
l'accélérateur de particules le plus
lumineux du monde environ 100 fois plus
que son prédécesseur le lep qui étaient
en fonctionnement ici même jusqu'en
novembre 2000 et comme nous allons le
voir pour espérer produire et détecter
le boson de higgs
il fallait cette luminosité
exceptionnelle je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que pour produire et détecter de
nouvelles particules
il suffisait d'avoir de l'énergie en
quantité suffisante mais c'est un petit
peu plus subtil que ça la création de
nouvelles particules repose sur des
interactions entre les particules qui
collision et que l'on peut grossièrement
comparer avec des réactions chimiques
les physiciens figure cela avec des
petits diagramme représentant les
particules est appelée diagramme de
feynman pour produire des bosons de
higgs dans le lhc
on compte notamment sur une réaction
appelé la fusion de glu lui il s'agit du
fait que 2 millions situé dans les
protons qui collision peuvent se
rencontrer interagir et donner un boson
de higgs
malheureusement les modèles théoriques
et les simulations nous permettent
d'estimer que ça ne se produit que dans
une collision sur un milliard
donc même avec 600 millions de
collisions par seconde faites le calcul
ça ne fait même pas un boson de higgs
produit par seconde de fonctionnement et
ça ce n'est que la moitié du chemin
car comme je lai déjà mentionné produire
de nouvelles particules c'est bien
encore faut-il pouvoir les capter et les
identifier
et ça c'est le travail des détecteurs je
me trouve maintenant à presque 100
mètres sous terre dans la caverne du
détecteur cms que voyait derrière moi il
s'agit de l'un des quatre principaux
détecteur actuellement présents sur le
lhc est celui qui avec le détecteur
atlas a permis la découverte du boson de
higgs
ce détecteur fait 21 mètres de long et
15 mètres de diamètre
il pèse 14 mille tonnes et sa conception
et son exploitation auront nécessité la
collaboration de plusieurs milliers de
scientifiques comme vous voyez on est
assez loin de la simple chambre à
brouillard qui avait permis la
découverte des murs la raison principale
de ce gigantisme et de toutes les
technologies qu'il a fallu employer
c'est que le boson de higgs est
incroyablement difficile à détecter
une fois créé sa durée de vie est infime
puisqu'il se désintègre au bout de
seulement dix puissance moins 22
secondes
c'est à dire un dix millième de
milliardième de milliardième de seconde
on connaît aucune méthode qui
permettrait de le détecter directement
dans ce laps de temps
la meilleure chose qu'on puisse espérer
faire c'est une détection indirecte
c'est à dire l'identifier au travers de
ces désintégration et nous allons voir
que c'est comme chercher une aiguille
dans une botte de foin quand une
collision se produit ce sont en effet au
total des dizaines de particules qui
peuvent être émises c'est ce que l'on
voit représentés sur les images de ce
type et tout le travail d'un détecteur
comme cms sera de reconstruire
correctement les trajectoires et les
caractéristiques de toutes les
particules créées afin de repérer celles
qui trahissent la désintégration d'un
boson de higgs qui auraient été produits
au moment de la collision
pour réaliser ce fastidieux travail de
reconstruction et d'identification un
des électeurs comme cms est conçu avec
une structure d'oignons cylindrique
il a en gros la forme d'un cylindre
enveloppant le point de collision dans
des particules sont produites lors de la
collision
elle traverse différentes couches de
capteurs ayant chacune une fonction bien
précise
au coeur du cylindre là où se produit la
rencontre des deux pesos et donc les
collisions se trouvent les
trajectographie il s'agit de minuscules
capteurs arrangé comme une matrice et
qui permettent d'identifier la position
des particules produites sans trop les
perturber en quelque sorte c'est comme
une caméra à 50 millions de pixels qui
pourrait voir des particules individuel
tout en fonctionnant à 40 millions 10
matches par semaine c'est
trajectographie ne détecte que les
particules chargées mais permettent de
reconstituer leur trajectoire à quelques
dizaines de micros
près grâce à un champ magnétique énorme
il est également possible d'identifier
certaines de leurs caractéristiques
comme leur impulsion ou leur énergie sur
la deuxième couche de l'oignon on trouve
le calorimètre électromagnétiques un
calorimètre c'est un appareil capable
d'intercepter certaines particules et en
les absorbant de mesurer leur énergie ce
premier calorimètre eddy
électromagnétiques car il peut absorber
les photons les positrons et les
électrons comme nous le verrons plus
tard il est essentiel de pouvoir
réaliser la mesure de l'énergie de ces
particules avec la meilleure précision
possible
pour cela le calorimètre
électromagnétiques de cms utilisent des
modules fait de cristaux scintillateurs
ultra purs en teintes stade de plomb il
aura fallu cinq ans de r&d et 10 ans de
production 24 heures sur 24 pour
produire l'ensemble des 76 mille
cristaux nécessaire à cms sur la couche
suivante se trouve le calorimètre à
azrou c'est un autre appareil dont la
fonction est de mesurer des énergies
mais cette fois pour les à dreux c'est à
dire les protons et les neutrons et les
autres particules fait de quark
la technique est différente de celle des
cristaux et utilise un sandwich alternée
de métaux et de plastique scintillateurs
et enfin sur la couche la plus externe
de cms se trouve le gros morceau les
chambres à mur en effet parmi toutes les
particules que l'on souhaite détecter et
analyser les muons sont celles qui
interagissent le moins avec la matière
et donc vont voyager le plus loin du
centre de collision sans être affectées
par les premières couches de détecteurs
pour pouvoir mesurer les
caractéristiques de sémillon et
notamment leur impulsion et leur énergie
on utilise un champ magnétique avec nos
structures bien particulière en
solénoïde c'est d'ailleurs lui qui donne
son nom à ce détecteur compact muon
solenoid il s'agit d'une énorme bobines
de matériaux supraconducteurs mesurant
13 mètres de long et 7 mètres de
diamètre et qui enveloppent une bonne
partie du détecteur elle produit un
champ de 4 tesla en faisant circuler un
courant de 20 mille ans perd en
conclusion grâce aux quatre couches de
détecteurs il est possible de repérer et
caractérisé presque toutes les
particules susceptibles d'être produites
lors d'une collision à l'exception des
neutrinos qui ne sont captés par aucun
détecteur mais dont on peut le deviner
la présence indirectement par un milan
d'énergie au total pour mettre au point
un détecteur comme cms
il a fallu imaginer des technologies de
pointe d'une fiabilité et d'une
résistance à toute épreuve
en effet avec presque
1 milliards de collisions par seconde
les dizaines de milliers de circuits
intégrés qui composent l'électronique de
ce détecteur sont soumis en permanence à
d'intenses radiations et pourtant ils
doivent préserver une fiabilité
exceptionnelle tout en fonctionnant à
une fréquence extrêmes puisque un
croisement se produit toutes les 25 nano
secondes sans compter qu'il est
évidemment très difficile d'ouvrir un
tel détecteur pour remplacer un
composant défectueux qui serait tombé en
panne
nous voici maintenant à l'étape suivante
de notre visite dans le centre de calcul
du cern
il s'agit d'une pièce essentielle du
dispositif puisque on l'a dit les
collisions se produise un rythme effréné
et seule une fraction infime d'entre
elles est susceptible de produire un
boson de higgs
quand un besoin de higgs est créé et se
désintègrent presque immédiatement
il peut le faire de plusieurs façons
différentes par exemple en un quark est
un anti quark bottom c'est le mode de
désintégration le plus fréquent presque
60% des cas ou encore en de bosons w de
gluons de photon etc
ce sont ce qu'on appelle les canaux de
désintégration la difficulté c'est qu'à
part le boson de higgs
il existe tout un tas d'autres
phénomènes susceptibles de produire
exactement les mêmes d intégration et
donc de conduire au même type de signal
dans les détecteurs pour avoir la
confirmation de l'existence du boson on
va donc devoir rechercher d anomalie
statistique
c'est à dire par exemple un excès de
désintégration d'un certain type par
rapport à ce qu'on attendrait si le
boson de higgs n'existait pas prenons un
exemple le cas où un boson de higgs se
désintègre en une paire de photons cette
courbe symbolise en fonction l'énergie
mesurer la quantité de paires de photons
qu'on est censé observer en l'absence de
boson de higgs juste du fait de tous les
autres phénomènes qui se produisent dans
les collisions
on appelle cela le background maintenant
imaginons que le boson de higgs existe
et que sa masse soi-disant 230
gigaélectron volt
alors le fait qu il se désintègre
parfois en une paire de photons devrait
se traduire par une petite bosse ici
vers 130 gigaélectron volt
ça c'est pour la désintégration en deux
photons mais on l'a dit il existe plein
d'autres canaux d intégration dans
lesquels recherché ce type de signal et
pour débusquer le boson de higgs tous
les canaux ne se valent pas l'idéal ce
sont les canaux où la taille de la bosse
soient suffisamment importantes par
rapport au background
c'est ce qu'on appelle le rapport signal
sur bruit
ce rapport dépend bien sûr de la
fréquence des désintégrations mais aussi
de la capacité des détecteurs à
reconstruire les trajectoires et mesurer
les énergies avec une bonne précision
au total parmi tous les canaux d
intégration possible les chercheurs de
cms et atlas ont d'abord concentré leurs
efforts sur deux en particulier celui de
la désintégration en deux photons dont
on a déjà parlé et dont la baisse
devrait être assez visible bien qu'ils
correspondent à un phénomène assez rare
un boson de higgs ne se désintégrera de
cette façon qu'une fois sur cinq sans
l'autre canal qui intéresse beaucoup les
chercheurs et celui qu'on surnomme le
canal en or il s'agit de la
désintégration en deux beaux 11 aides
qui se désintègre ensuite même en deux
paires de leptons les leptons ici ce
sont des millions des électrons ou
l'argentine particules c'est un
phénomène encore plus rare
il se produit une fois sur dix mille
mais il est assez spécifique du boson de
higgs est donc le background devrait
être faible
cela devrait se traduire par une bosse
bien visible dans les courbes
ça c'était pour la théorie mais une des
difficultés majeures dans cette traque
du boson de higgs
c'est la quantité astronomique de
données qu'il va falloir traiter
on l'a dit il y à 30 millions de
croisement par seconde et à chaque
croisement ce sont en moyenne 20
collision et des centaines de particules
qui peuvent être produites est captée
par les différents systèmes d'un
détecteur comme cms
si on prend en compte toutes les données
produites par toutes les parties du
détecteur cela représente environ 1000
téraoctets de données par seconde donc
de quoi remplir mille disques durs
environ à chaque seconde
il est évidemment impossible de stocker
et d'analyser une telle quantité de
données
il faut donc trouver un moyen de réduire
la collecte pour cela à chaque
croisement donc 30 millions de fois par
seconde des équipements électroniques
spécifiques appelés trigger effectué des
analyses préliminaires pour déterminer
si cela vaut le coup de conserver les
données correspondantes
si elles peuvent conduire ou pas à la
détection d'un boson de higgs ce tri
s'effectue en 3 microsecondes en
essayant de repérer des signaux
intéressants et permet de conserver les
données que d'un croisement sur 40000 ce
qui en stockage est évidemment beaucoup
plus gérable
ces données sont alors sauvegarder et
répartis sur 140 centres de calcul
situés partout dans le monde qui
procéderont à l'analyse des signaux
comme vous vous en doutez je passe
encore sous silence
énormément de prouesses techniques liées
au fonctionnement des détecteurs et à
l'analyse des données car il est temps
maintenant de parler de ce qui a été
annoncé ici dans le grand auditorium du
cern
le 4 juillet 2012 l'image que vous voyez
maintenant a été montré le jour de
l'annoncé par le porte parole de la
collaboration cms un we knew date des se
voit du sud so bad for icing ne fait que
ce graphique concerne la désintégration
en deux photons et représente le nombre
de paires de photons détecté en fonction
de leur énergie en noir ce sont les
données mesurées par cms et en
pointillés rouges c'est le background
c'est à dire le calcul théorique de ce
qu'on attendrait en l'absence de boson
de x comme vous le constatez on observe
une petite bosse autour de 125
gigaélectron volt
ce qui est un signe qui trahit la
présence d'une particule nouvelles ayant
cette masse comme je les mentionnaient
deux expériences en parallèle avec comme
mission de détecter le fameux boson cms
et atlas deux détecteurs fonctionnant
indépendamment et selon des principes de
conception différents un peu plus tard
lors de la conférence la porte parole de
la collaboration atlas a montré le
graphique correspondant pour ce
détecteur on y voit le même type de boss
dans la même gamme d'énergie la courbe
située juste en dessous représente
l'excès par rapport au background
comme vous pouvez le voir on ne parle
pas d'une quantité énorme au total ce
sont seulement quelques centaines de
photos en trop qui ont été trouvés dans
ces intervalles d'énergie on comprend
d'ailleurs la nécessité d'être capable
d'estimer avec une très bonne résolution
l'énergie des photons
si la résolution avait été moins bonnes
la bosse aurait été complètement et
aller et on n'aurait rien pu conclure
intuitivement on pourrait penser que ces
deux résultats concordants de deux
expériences indépendante serait
suffisant pour annoncer la découverte du
boson de higgs
mais non car les physiciens des
particules ont des critères statistiques
très exigeant et pour être autorisé à
annoncer une telle découverte
il faut un niveau de preuve encore plus
élevé heureusement les deux expériences
atlas et cms ont pu regarder l'autre
canal de désintégration dont on a parlé
celui où un boson de higgs se désintègre
en 2 boson z puis 4 leptons le fameux
canal en or un canal très sensible mais
correspondant à des intégrations très
rare voici un graphique correspondant
pour cms on voit ici le background en
bleu en point noir les données mesurées
et en rouge ce qu'on attendrait de la
présence d'un boson de higgs dans la
zone des 125 gigaélectron volt la beauce
est bien là mais comme vous le voyez
ça ne correspond qu'à un très petit
nombre d'événements excédentaire moins
d'une dizaine et voici la courbe
équivalente pour atlas au total en
combinant les deux canaux les physiciens
des expériences atlas et cms ont pu
atteindre le seuil statistique au delà
duquel on est autorisé à annoncer la
découverte d'une nouvelle particule
depuis on a beaucoup affiner les
résultats en effet bien plus de
collisions ont été enregistrées
c'est une mesure qu'on appelle la
luminosité intégré et les résultats ont
été bien évidemment confirmé comme on le
voit sur cette courbe où les bars
d'erreurs sont bien plus faibles et la
bosse beaucoup plus nette
à ce stade on pourrait se dire que les
résultats des collaboration atlas et cms
montre seulement l'existence d'une
nouvelle particule
mais s'agit-il bien du boson de higgs eh
bien il faut savoir qu'on a pu vérifier
aussi que les pourcentages des
différents modes de désintégration
collait parfaitement avec ce qu'on
attendait du boson de higgs
en plus de la confirmation du fait qu'il
est comme prévu un spin égal à zéro
comme vous le savez certainement suite à
la découverte du boson de higgs en 2012
le prix nobel de physique 2013 a été
attribué à pieter ickx et françois
angles r2 des théoriciens qui lie à 50
ans avaient imaginé dans leurs calculs
l'existence du boson le compatriote et
coauteur de françois anglais robert brut
étant malheureusement décédé en mai 2011
sans avoir pu vivre la découverte
quand on voit tout le travail accompli
ici on se dit que le prix aurait aussi
pu aller aux physiciens qui ont réalisé
ces formidables expériences mais par
tradition le prix nobel de physique
n'est attribuée qu'à des individus et
pas à des groupes et il aurait été
difficile de nous distinguer que
quelques personnes parmi les milliers de
scientifiques ayant collaboré sur près
de trois décennies pour rendre cet
exploit possible
[Musique]
aujourd'hui si nous avons pu faire cette
visite exceptionnelle au cern
c'est parce que le lhc est en arrêt
temporaire pour réaliser des opérations
de maintenance et d'amélioration j'ai
donc voulu interroger les physiciens du
cern
pour en savoir plus sur ce qui se
prépare alors oui effectivement ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on a découvert le
besoin de nick mais il ya encore
beaucoup de mesures beaucoup d'études et
analyses pour bien comprendre les
propriétés de boson de higgs ni on
connaît les couplages 2 x 10 des
différents couplage mieux on peut
comprendre les propriétés de particules
être sûr que c'est vraiment le besoin de
x tel qu on le pense on cherche parfois
de l un des événements qui sont très
rares et donc plus en 1 à 2 de donner
plus on a la possibilité de voir quelque
chose
les jeunes grecs ça consiste surtout à
augmenter le nombre de collisions dans
la trachée par un facteur 10 donc c'est
à dire que au point de collision on doit
augmenter la densité du faisceau dans la
lancée on a des éléments qui font 8 et
cela en général on veut augmenter 7,7
sur meetic dans l'année prochain on va
installer des aimants qui font en cela
par rapport à 8 et cela donc pour faire
ça il faut compter le court donc pour ça
on utilise typiquement des nouvelles
type de nouvelle génération de des
matériaux donc par rapport au niveau du
titan on va étudier au m3 est et dans
quelques dates dans une danse autour de
cinq 5 ans on va installer des éléments
qui font une focus groups plus fort pour
mieux concentrer les particules et pour
pouvoir avoir plus de luminosité donc
plus de collisions entre particules
actuellement lhc a été conçu pour une
luminosité comme indice ppi sont 34 et
la luminosité pic pour lâcher la c1 et
lumino c'était lhc sera 2 10 pesos 35
une grande luminosité vrai
voudrait dire plus de statistiques plus
de d'événements donc avoir plus de
statistiques plus de luminosité peut
être est il est par contre ça fait si on
travaille sur cette lumineuse topic
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de traces
dans les expériences et les expériences
arrive plus à distinguer les différentes
origines de ses traces pour les
détecteurs ça devient beaucoup plus
difficile dans ces cas-là mais donc de
vraiment des deux du à chelles et lhc on
va avoir au lieu de 2 35
on va dire collision par croisement en
moyenne là on va avoir à peu près 200
religion pas par croisant augmenter si
ou lé le taux de collision dans le
détecteur c'est quelque chose dont on a
besoin pour chercher des phénomènes
rares sauf que ensuite il faut quand
même être capables de 2,10 voir clair
dans la production de milliers de
particules en même temps on avait besoin
d'avoir un détecteur beaucoup plus
segmentée pour pouvoir être capable de
mesurer l'énergie des particules
séparément donc à l'avant on est on est
en train de concevoir cette fois-ci
calorimètre complètement innovant s'agit
donc de faire un détecteur hautement
granulaires ce qu'on appelle un
calorimètre imageur qui est à la fois en
fait la combinaison d'un détecteur de
trace donc une trajectoire aph et d'un
calorimètre là dans ce cas là on va
justement segmenté donc en avant en
ayant des partis et d'absorbeurs et des
parties actives sait qu'on va être
capable de séparer les particules entre
elles donc vraiment être capable de
suivre le parcours de la particule et
son dépôt d'énergie donc c'est quand
même un projet de très innovant est
aussi extrêmement compliqué à réaliser
parce que imaginer qu un calorimètre
aujourd'hui comme le calories mène de
cms on a 75 1848 cristaux de tincques
stade de plomb là le agecale leurs
animateurs qui se retrouve à l'avant du
détecteur seulement
on parle de 6 millions de canon il faut
voir qu'avec la montée du lhc en
puissance donc on est obligé de faire
des calculs plus poussées pour être
capable de rejeter beaucoup plus de
bruit de fond qu'avant donc cet objet il
est développé par les ingénieurs
électroniciens qui travaille sur les
expériences lhc et c'est une nouvelle
génération de systèmes de déclenchement
dont le but ça va être de séparer de
manière plus efficace et les électrons
les photons par rapport au bruit de fond
est donc là on devrait gagner un facteur
2 à 3 sur la réduction du bruit de fond
et ça c'est c'est crucial pour qu'on
puisse bénéficier des nouvelles données
qui arrivant du lhc le besoin d'être un
as découvert donc c'est un fan
particules mais il ya des modèles 1 qui
prédisent un campement avoir plusieurs
types de besoins de xxi je prends un
exemple de supersymétrie on va avoir
cinq besoins de x3 besoin de avec notre
aide au besoin de x qui sont chargés et
le boson de higgs qu'on a découvert
saurait
la particule enfin le besoin le plus
légère en outre il ya aussi des
recherches aussi un qui peuvent nous
permet de voir éventuellement les
particules qui sont les candidats pour
la matière noire elle même donc en
supersymétrie et aurait une particule un
autre qui interagit très très faiblement
qui peut être une bonne candidate pour
la matière noire et cette particule
pourraient être générés en même temps
que d'autres particules le lhc
ça peut être un à la porte est justement
de nouveau rang de l'est dans
l'expérience lhcb il y à des déviations
qui sont déjà observés par les
prédictions avec les prédictions du
modèle standard
et justement il n'y a pas assez de
statistiques pour l'instant pour pouvoir
confirmer ces déviations là si c'est
vraiment dessine une nouvelle physique
ou pas et a beaucoup d'espoir qu'avec le
nouveau rond de lhc on va avoir
suffisamment de données pour enfin bien
comprendre ce qu'on a découvert quelque
chose de nouveau ou est-ce qu'il ya deux
trois raisons à sa déviation est en plus
dans le futur on peut aussi augmenter si
on change les dépose on peut augmenter
aussi le résident les particules pour le
même
circonférence de a lâché ou si on
augmente aussi une circonférence de 27 à
100 km par exemple on peut bien
augmenter l'énergie des particules pour
avoir des conclusions qui sont très
intéressants maintenant on est autour de
13 à 14 à 14 tel électeur vote
et là on peut augmenter peut-être faire
une centaine de lettres en france un des
principaux espoirs des physiciens
aujourd'hui c'est donc que le lhc
finissent par nous révéler quelque chose
d'inattendu des phénomènes nouveaux
qu'on ne comprendraient pas et qui nous
permettrait d'aller plus loin
en effet il reste toujours aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de questions ouvertes
en physique fondamentale qu'est ce que
la matière noire
pourquoi y at-il plus de matière que
d'antimatière et surtout comment unifier
la mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale et des éléments de réponse à
ces questions pourraient donc surgir des
futures expériences qui seront menées
ici au lhc dans les années à venir
[Musique]